SO ALL RIGHT WE'RE VERY TO GET
STARTED HERE- WHEN I THANK YOU
ALL FOR ATTENDING ASSEMBLY A
MILITARY VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE WE WILL CALL THIS
MEETING TO ORDER- WE HAVE AND WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BUT WE'RE
GOING TO START TO CAN MOVE
FORWARD WITH OUR BUSINESS AS A-
AS A SUB COMMITTEE. I WANT TO
WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY MILITARY
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
WHETHER YOU ARE HERE IN PERSON
OR WATCHING VIRTUALLY. I AM
GRATEFUL- YOU HAVE JOINED US
TODAY. BILLS WILL BE HEARD AND
FOLLOW ORDER WE HAVE ONE BILL
ALL THE OTHERS ARE ON CONSENT.
TODAY'S HEARING IS IN PERSON
WITH PHONE TESTIMONY AVAILABLE.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON EACH BILL WILL
BE AVAILABLE. AFTER AUTHOR
TESTIMONY. AND WILL HEAR UBLIC
COMMENT FROM THOSE PRESENT THEN
FROM THOSE CALLING IN. AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE. WE STILL
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FOR A QUORUM.
TWENTY SIX YOU CAN FIND ANYONE
LIKE ME ONE MORE. ONE TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE. ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD- MOVE FORWARD AS
A SUB COMMITTEE AND WELCOME OUR-
OUR FIRST PRESENTATION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- QUIRK-SILVA AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE. NO. TO
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR RAMOS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FIRST
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT WHO WORKED WITH US ON
ANALYZING THIS BILL. TODAY I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB FIFTEEN
NINETY FIVE A DISTRICT BILL THAT
WILL ALLOW FOR A STATE VETERANS
CEMETERY LOCATED IN THE COUNTY
OF ORANGE UPON COMPLETION OF A
SITE SURVEY. I AM PLEASED TO
INFORM THE COMMITTEE THAT THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE IS THE SPONSOR
OF AB FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE THE
GYPSUM CANYON SITE LOCATION HAS
RECEIVED SUPPORT FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENTS VIA
RESOLUTIONS PASSED BY ALL THIRTY
OR SO. IN THE COUNTY LAST YEAR
INCLUDING THE CITY OF IRVINE.
ALONG WITH THE COUNTY AND ALL
THIRTY FOUR CITIES IN ADDITION
TO NUMEROUS SIGNIFICANT VETERAN
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE SUBMITTED AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE SUPPORT
LETTERS SUCH AS SUCH GROUPS AS
THE AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTMENT
OF CALIFORNIA. AMVETS AMERICAN
GOLD STAR MOTHERS VIETNAM
VETERANS OF AMERICA AND OTHER
NOTABLE VETERAN CENTERED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL POSTS.
AS SOON AS SOME OF YOU MIGHT
ALREADY KNOW I STARTED WORKING
WITH ORANGE COUNTY VETERANS BACK
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN VIA AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE. WHICH WAS
CHAPTER THEN AB THREE SIXTY
EIGHT ALSO CHAPTER TO IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND NOW A THIRD TIME
WITH AB FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO DUE TO LACK OF
LOCAL SUPPORT. SO I'M GONNA OFF
OF MY OF THE PREPARED REMARKS
HERE AND SOME OF YOU HAVE TO
WORK STEADFAST WITH ME AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOM DALY WHO
WORKED WHEN I WAS NOT HERE- TO
CONTINUE OUR EFFORTS TO BRING AN
ORANGE COUNTY VETERANS CEMETERY
. HOW AND WHEN DID THIS START
THIS STARTED WHEN I WAS ELECTED
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AND A LOCAL
GROUP OF VETERANS WHO HAD BEEN
WORKING. AMONGST THEMSELVES WITH
THE VISION TO BRING AN ORANGE
COUNTY CEMETERY I WAS ONLY THERE
VOICE AND THEN AS I BECAME CHAIR
OF THE VETERANS COMMITTEE THEN
TOOK THIS ON. OF COURSE WE WOULD
HAVE ALREADY LIKED TO HAVE HAD A
VETERANS CEMETERY BUILT WE HAD
FIRST ONE SITE THE ARTIST SITE
THEN ANOTHER SITE A POTENTIAL
STRAWBERRY SITE AND THAT A THIRD
SAW THE GULF SITE. ALL WITHIN
THE CITY OF IRVINE WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN VERY BLESSED TO HAVE ANY OF
THOSE SITES BUT BECAUSE OF LOCAL
OPPOSITION AND NOT HAVING THE
SUPPORT FROM THE CITY OF IRVINE
NOT ME BUT THE VALUE IS GROUP
MOVED ON TO A NEW SITE. WHICH IS
NOW THE GYPSUM CANYON SIDE. I'VE
ONLY BEEN THERE VOICE TO TAKE
THEIR LEAD AND AN EFFORT TO
BRING THIS ORANGE COUNTY
VETERANS CEMETERY TO ORANGE
COUNTY. MY FATHER MY BROTHER AND
MY NEPHEW IS WHO IS SERVING IN
THE MARINE HOW CAN OUR ALL RIGHT
THIS IS NOT ONLY AND TO ME
THOUSANDS OF MILITARY FAMILIES.
THE COUNTY OF WARREN SUPPORTS
ITS VETERANS IN THE SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTY AND WE OWE THIS TO
THEM AS PLACE TO CALL HOME. AND
TO THEIR FAMILIES MANY OF YOU
MAY KNOW THAT THERE IS A
RIVERSIDE CEMETERY BUT THAT
CEMETERY HAS BEEN FILLED WITH A
LONG WAITING LIST THIS WOULD BE
A PLACE IN ORANGE COUNTY. WITH
ME HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE IS UNITED
STATES MARINE CORPS VETERAN AND
COMBAT VETERAN OF THE VIETNAM
WAR MISTER NICK VERA DINO. AND I
ALSO HAVE TODAY. IN SUPPORT
BUSINESSES AMY JENKINS PRESIDENT
A POSITION ADVOCACY THE LOBBYIST
FOR ORANGE COUNTY WHO ARE THE
SPONSORS OF AB FIFTEEN NINETY
FIVE. MISTER BEAR DINO THANK YOU
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND HONORABLE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NICK
DO YOU KNOW. I AM THE PRESIDENT
OF THE VETERANS ALLIANCE OF
ORANGE COUNTY. TODAY I'M PROUDLY
PROUDLY REPRESENTING A COALITION
THAT WE BUILT SINCE MAY. OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN. VETERAN
ORGANIZATIONS. WHICH IS JOINED
BY A HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN
BIPARTISAN ELECTED OFFICIALS.
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE EVERY CITY
EVERY CITY IN ORANGE COUNTY ALL
THIRTY FOUR CITIES INCLUDING
IRVINE. IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE. ORANGE
COUNTY VETERANS HAVE BEEN LACED
IN A MIDDLE OF A POLITICAL
CROSSFIRE. RELATED TO BUILDING
AND STATE VETERANS CEMETERY FOR
THE PAST TEN YEARS OVER TEN
YEARS. UNFORTUNATELY MEMBERS OF
OUR REGIONAL COMMITTEE WHOSE
SERVICE AND SACRIFICE TO OUR
GREAT NATION. SHOULD HAVE BEEN
HONORED WITH THE FINAL RESTING
PLACE IN THEIR COMMUNITY HAVE
DIED DURING THIS TENURE STRUGGLE
FOR SENATOR. ADDITIONALLY
VIETNAM VETERANS HAVE ONCE AGAIN
BEEN IS TREATED IN AND CANDIDLY
TRAUMATIZED AS A RESULT OF BEING
USED AS POLITICAL CHESS PIECES.
FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS. WE HAVE
A SITE WHICH- IS SUPPORTED BY
THE ENTIRE COUNTY. THE ENTIRE
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY. WE
ASKED WHEN OUR COUNTRY ASKED US
TO FIGHT. FOR OUR NATION WE
FOUGHT. WE SACRIFICED. TO
PRESERVE THIS WONDERFUL
DEMOCRACY. THAT YOU HAVE ALL
BEEN ENTRUSTED. TO PRESERVE AND
ADMINISTER. AND WE VETERANS
WE'VE NEVER TURNED OUR BACKS ON
YOU NEVER. SO TODAY I'M PLEADING
WITH YOU I'M PLEADING WITH YOU.
I'M TAKING WITH YOU NOT TO TURN
YOUR BACKS ON US. AND VOTE YES
ON THIS BILL WHICH WILL PROVIDE
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
VETERANS. A DIGNIFIED RESTING
PLACE IN A COMMUNITY WHICH THEY
CALL HOME AND FOR ONE MORE
SECOND JUST ON A PERSONAL NOTE.
THIS IS BEEN THE WORST THING
I'VE EVER BEEN THROUGH IN TERMS
OF POLITICAL BUSINESS. I HAVE
BEEN COMING TO THE CAPITAL SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE AND THEN
I RETIRED SIX YEARS AGO. I NEVER
THOUGHT I NEVER THOUGHT. THAT I
WOULD HAVE TO LIMP OVER HERE
WITH OTHER VETS. YOU CAN'T EVEN
WALK ANYMORE. TO COME AND PLEAD
FOR A FINAL PLACE TO BE AREAS.
THAT'S ALL WE WANT PLEASE PLEASE
VOTE FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY HAS BEEN EMOTIONAL
SECOND. THANK YOU FOR THE TEST
BY ANY OTHER- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. YES MISTER CHAIRMAN AMY
JENKINS- ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAVE
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THINKING
ASSEMBLY WOMAN QUIRK-SILVA FOR
HER STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO THIS
ISSUE. THIS IS A LONG AWAITED-
POLICY CHANGE WE NEED TO BUILD A
VETERANS CEMETERY IN ORANGE
COUNTY SO OUR VETERANS HAVE A
PLACE TO REST. AB FIFTEEN NINETY
FIVE WOULD ALLOW CALVET TO
DESIGN DEVELOP AND CONSTRUCT A
STATE OPERATED VETERANS SUMMIT.
WHICH COUNTY AND AS- THE AUTHOR
AND THIS OTHER SPONSOR MY
COLLEAGUE NICK VERY DINO THERE
IS WIDE COMMUNITY BASED SUPPORT
FOR THIS- IN ADDITION TO THAT
ORANGE COUNTY HAS COMMITTED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
EXCLUSIVELY FOR THE SITE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE CEMETERY. AND
AS PREVIOUSLY. TWO HUNDRED. OF
CAN ONLY A AT CHIP CAN IN
ANAHEIM HILLS FOR THIS PURPOSE
AS PREVIOUSLY STATED AGAIN WE
HAVE VERY VERY BROAD BASED
COMMUNITY SUPPORT. AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL TODAY
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT. THANK YOU
FOR THAT- ANY SUPPORT IN THE. BY. ANY SUPPORT IN THE ROOM PLEASE
STEP UP TO THE MIKE STATE YOUR
POSITION.
ROBERT BROWER ORANGE COUNTY
RESIDENT. AND LEGISLATIVE
COMMISSIONER FOR AREA FIVE OF
THE AMERICAN LEGION WHICH THE
ENTIRE DEPARTMENT OF THE
AMERICAN LEGION SUPPORTS THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SET THREE WITH READ
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING HIM VETS DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
COMMANDERS COUNCIL COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL COMPRISED OF
TWENTY TWO VETERAN ORGANIZATIONS
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
CHAPTERS IN THE VIETNAM VETERANS
OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL ON STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY
OTHERS IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT.
GOING TO THE PHONES DO YOU HAVE
ANY ON THE PHONES IN SUPPORT.
GERMAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF. AB FIFTEEN NINETY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THAT IS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND FIRST
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS GAIL PENNINGTON MY
HUSBAND WHO IS NOW DECEASED IS A
MILITARY VETERAN AND WE MADE OUR
HOME HERE IN IRVINE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY AND HAVE LIVED HERE EVER
SINCE AND AYE OPPOSE A. B.
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE- BECAUSE WE
WANT TO BE. AS CEMETERY TO BE
HERE AND IRVINE NOT AT THE
GYPSUM CANYON SITE. THREE OTHERS
ON THE PHONE LINE INCIDENT OR AT
THE SPRING CARE. NEXT ONE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ELAINE BRITTAIN AND
I'M CURRENTLY SERVING MY THIRD
TERM AS THE NATIONAL CHAPLAIN OF
AMERICAN GOLD STAR MOTHERS AND
THE PRESIDENT THE LOCAL CHAPTER
HERE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN GOLD STAR MOTHERS IS AN
ORGANIZATION OF MOTHERS WHO LOST
SONS AND DAUGHTERS IN SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTRY THEREFORE WE THE
MOTHERS WITHOUT PROVISIONS
SUPPORT EIGHT. FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. YES HELLO MY NAME IS
BILL COOK ON A SEVENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD MARINE CORPS VIETNAM VETERAN
CHAIRMAN OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
VETERANS MEMORIAL. ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. ONE MOMENT. FIFTY I'M
SORRY YOU GOT CUT OFF PLEASE GO
AHEAD MY NAME IS STEVE SPRIGGS A
MEMBER OF AMERICAN LEGION AND
VFW IN ORANGE COUNTY VIETNAM
VETERANS SEVENTY FOUR YEARS OLD
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO YES GO AHEAD
AND- YEAH MY NAME IS A BOBBY
MCDONALD ON THE UNITED STATES
NAVY VIETNAM VETERAN AND I
PRESENT THE BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ORANGE COUNTY. THE- THE
BLACK OF THE BLACK WHICH
COUNTIES DON'T COUNTY SEPTEMBER
THE BOAT MULTIPOINT ARRANGED THE
BUFFALO SOLDIERS THE TUSKEGEE
AIRMEN AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU BUT- HELLO YES GO
AHEAD IN SUPPORT PLEASE STATE
YOUR POSITION. MY NAME IS WAYNE
YOST I AM THE SENIOR VICE
COMMANDER FOR VETERANS OF
FOREIGN WARS DISTRICT TWO OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. VETERANS
HAVE FOUGHT BLED AND DIED FOR
OUR COUNTRY PLEASE GIVE THIR
FAMILIES A PLACE FOR THEIR
RESTING IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
THEIR HOMES. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
JAKE ADAMS I REPRESENT THE
BRAILLE VETERANS CLUB I'M EIGHTY
FIVE YEARS OLD FROM AN ARMY AND
EIGHTY FIVE YEARS OLD I BEG YOU
PLEASE SUPPORT A. B. FIFTEEN
NINETY FIVE. I KEPT. HELLO YES
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS RON BEN GO
SHEA I'M A NATIVE OF ORANGE
COUNTY I AM A MEMBER OF VETERANS
HELPING VETERANS THAT REPRESENT
A SMALL VOICE FOR ALL THE
VETERANS FAMILIES LOVED ONES IN
SUPPORT OF STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE. AND I'D
LIKE TO SEE ALL EYES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MANY OTHERS.
YES MY NAME IS BILL SAMMON- OF
IT MOM BIT MARINE VET AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU YOU. HI MY
NAME IS CHASE WICKER SHAM I AM A
VIETNAM COMBAT VETERAN MEMBER
THE AMERICAN LEGION AND VFW IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND ALSO A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY VETERAN MILITARY FAMILY
COLLABORATIVE AND- I STRONGLY
SUPPORTED THE FIFTEEN NINETY
FIVE. THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME
IS PETE SITES AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE GREATER LOS
ANGELES CHAPTER OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF THE UNITED STATES
ARMY. AND ALSO THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY VETERANS AND
MILITARY FAMILIES COLLABORATIVE
AND IM ALSO A MARINE AND ARMY
VETERAN. AND STRONG SUPPORTERS
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE THANK. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHARLES BARFIELD AND I'M THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
A PROUD MEMBER OF THE VALOR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
WADE I'M A MEMBER OF POST TO
NINETY ONE AMERICAN LEGION POST
NEWPORT BEACH B. F. W. THIRTY
ONE SEVENTY THREE ANAHEIM AND
I'M DISTRIT DIRECTOR AND
VETERANS LIAISON TO SUPERVISOR
BETWEEN A FULLY ALONG WITH ALL
FOUR OF HER COLLEAGUES ON THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THIS BILL ABC FIFTEEN NINETY
FIVE NEEDS TO PASS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS A
BILL PULLMAN I AM A MEMBER OF
THE DISABLED AMERICAN VETERANS
OF ORANGE COUNTY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB ONE FIVE NINE FIVE
AND I AM ALSO IN ANAHEIM HILLS
RESIDENT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LARRY
LARSON I'M A VIETNAM ERA ARMY
VETERAN- I LIVE IN ANAHEIM HILLS
NOT NO GREATER HONOR FOR ANY OF
US THAN TO HAVE A VETERANS
CEMETERY IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD-
STRONGLY SUPPORT A BE FIFTEEN
NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NORM
SILVERS BERMAN EIGHTY EIGHT YEAR
OLD UNITED STATES AIR FORCE
VETERAN SERVING STATESIDE. I
STRONGLY URGE THAT YOU PASS
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHELLE DELA CRUZ I'M THE
FOUNDING COMMANDER OF POST EIGHT
THREE EIGHT AND IRVINE I AM
INVOLVED WITH THE DAUGHTERS OF
THE AMERICAN REVOLUTION THE-
FORTY AND EIGHT THE AMERICAN
LEGION RIDERS PATRIOT GUARD
RIDERS I'M ASKING YOU THIS
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN
NINETY FIVE AND GIVE OUR
VETERANS AS- NON CONTRA. RESTFUL
PLACE FOR OUR THEIR FAMILIES TO
BURY THEM PLEASE. THANK YOU.
THAT'S ALL WE HAVE ON OUR LINE.
THANK YOU- DOUBLE CHECK IT ONE
MORE TANK ANY OTHER CALLERS IN
SUPPORT. MANY MEMBERS IN THE
CHAMBERS IN SUPPORT. MOVING ON
TO OUR- OPPOSITION IS- TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WHO
STEP FORWARD.
OKAY HERE IT'S MUCH EASIER.
HONORABLE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I AM
HARVEY LIST EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE BILL THE GREAT PARK
VETERANS CEMETERY. JOHN GELLER.
SITTING TO MY RIGHT AND I ARE
LONG TIME RESIDENTS IRVINE. WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN
NINETY FIVE. UNLESS AMENDED.
BECAUSE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
STATE VETERANS CEMETERY AT THE
ORIGINAL HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
ACRE ARTIST SITE. DESIGNATED IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND
SITUATED ON THE HISTORIC FORMER
MCAS EL TORO. THIS HALLOWED
GROUND ISNOW PART OF THE GREAT
PARK IN IRVINE. AND THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO REASON THAT THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VETERANS
CEMETERY CANNOT STAY AT THE ARE
THE SITE EXCEPT FOR A
RECALCITRANT CITY COUNCIL SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. BY THE
WAY YOUR CONSULTANT DID A GREAT
JOB ON THE ANALYSIS STATING
SUCCINCTLY ON PAGE TWO AND I
QUOTE. OPPONENTS THAT'S US MAKE
SEVERAL ARGUMENTS IN OPPOSITION
MANY AROUND THE CONTENTION THAT
THE ARTIST SITE ON THE FORMER.
MCAS EL TORO IS SUPERIOR BECAUSE
OF ITS LOCATION IS HAVING BEEN
STUDIED AND APPROVED ITS
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE. ITS
ZONING STATUS. ADDITIONALLY
OPPONENTS SAY A NEW IRVINE CITY
COUNCIL MAY YET DECIDE TO
TRANSFER THE ARE THE PARCEL TO
THE STATE. IRVINE CITIZENS
OVERWHELMINGLY WANT THE CEMETERY
ON THE ARTIST SITE AND THEY WILL
VOTE FOR A NEW SUPPORTIVE CITY
COUNCIL ON NOVEMBER EIGHTH.
THANK YOU HARVEY. IT SEEMS
SENSELESS FOR THIS BILL TO
STRIKE OUT THE PREFER A BOWL ARE
TO SITE AND THEN NOT SPECIFY
THOSE ENDORSEMENTS AT THE END OF
THE ANALYSIS WELL THEY WERE ALL
GATHERED BASED UPON THE FALSE
PREMISE THAT THE ARTIST SITE WAS
DEAD. FURTHER SHIPS IN CANYON IS
ONLY TWO MILES FROM THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BORDER. ALL
VETERANS WANTS IS A CENTRALLY
LOCATED STATE OR NATIONAL
CEMETERY WHERE THEY CAN USE
THEIR FULL PROMISED BURIAL
BENEFITS AND THE CENTRALLY
LOCATED ARTIST SITES IS THE
PERFECT LOCATION. SO WE
RECOMMEND PUTTING BACK THE
ALREADY STUDIED ARTIST SITES AND
SPECIFYING THAT THE JIBSON
CANYON SITES BE STUDIED ALSO.
THE AMOUNT ALLOCATED FOR A
THOROUGH STUDY SHOULD NOT BE
LIMITED TO ONLY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GIVEN THAT THE
COURSE- STUDY COSTS THAT AMOUNT
AND DIDN'T HAVE THE GEOTECHNICAL
ENVIRONMENTAL OR LAND USE
PROBLEMS. LASTLY REQUIRE THAT
RATHER THAN THE STATE SO THE
VETERANS FUND IS NOT FURTHER
DEPLETED. IN OTHER WORDS PLEASE
REFER TO SENATE BILL NUMBER
FORTY THREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- COMMENTS IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. ANY OPPOSITION THE ROOM. ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
CENTERMAN TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IN FIRST WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES RETIRED UNITED STATES
AIR FORCE VETERAN VIETNAM COMBAT
VETERAN I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE AS IT IS
WRITTEN TIME TO GET ALSO
CEMETERY IN ORANGE COUNTY AT THE
REGIONAL PLEDGE. AT THE GREAT
PARK THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND ONE MOMENT I HAVE.
FOURTEEN NINETEEN Q. RICHEST
DEFINING LINE NUMBERS. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. US ARMY VET I
LIVE IRVINE I'M NOT A LIFE
MEMBER OF THE VFW. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. FIFTEEN
NINETY FIVE WITHOUT THE
INCLUSION OF THE ART OF SITES AS
PART OF THE STRUCTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE HAVE
LINED ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ROBERTA
PALATINI I'M A LONG TIME IRVINE
RESIDENTS I VOTED FOR. THEM TO
CARRY OUT THE ARTIST BY WE WANT
A CEMETERY AND- FIND OUT AND WE
- FOR FURTHER DIED CENTRAL A
LOCATED IN THE MIDDLE STRUCTURE. THANK YOU ANY OF THOSE IN
OBJECT YOU STATE DRIVES.
NECKLINE ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO.
HELLO YES. MY NAME IS NOT BEING
ABLE SHMORAH. I AM AN ENGINEER
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BRIDGE ENGINEER AND I AM A
CERTIFICATED FOR THIRTY ONE
YEARS AND BUILDING BRIDGES FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
RETROFITTING BRIDGES FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I HOPPED I
HAVE NO OBJECTION TO BUILDING A
VETERANS CEMETERY FOR OUR
HONORABLE VETERANS HOWEVER. THIS
YEAR I AM A GAME TO OPPOSE THE
STATE'S BELL. AND I FIFTEEN
NINETY FIVE. I AM BUT I OF YOUR
BELINDA. I LIVED THEM AND- ONE
POINT SEVEN MILES A FROM THE AGE
CANYON SITE AND THE AMOUNT THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OFF A TOPIC
THAT'S WE ALREADY HAVE. IMPACT
IMPACT THE LOCAL STREETS AND THE
FREEWAY THE NINETY ONE FREEWAY.
AND BOTH SIDES. AND IT IS AND
WESTBOUND. EIGHT CREATES IT'S
GONNA CREATE TIME MAN QUICKNESS. THREE NOT ONLY THAT THAT HAVE
JOB AND TRICOLOR. EFFECT UPON MY
FARM AND THAT I DID OFF BIDS
THIS STEP THE CITY THANK BECAUSE. THANK YOU WE NEED TO MOVE.
THANKS HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND NEXT
WE HAVE LINED ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
THEIR OR BOARD TRAINING- I JUST
WANTED TO. THE BILL. GENERATED.
BUT IT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- NEXT HEADLINE WE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
TO COME A RESIDENT OF THE AND
I'M HILLS AREA PROXY OF THE
PROPOSED SITE I. BY VERY
STRONGLY OF AB FIFTY NINE FIVE
AND I CENTER BROUGHT OUR
LOCATION I LIKE RESIDENTS NOW
I'M AND I'M BUILDING BILL AND I
NO. NEXT HEADLINE ONE FOR FIVE
PLEASE GO. MY NAME IS BOB GILMAN
I'M A THIRTY YEAR THAN ABSOLUTE
- BATTLE. YUP AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. FOR THE AND-
THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE LINED ONE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACKIE STARLET
AND THIS IS IN A VERY LONG SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FIFTY NINETY FIVE WE
HAVE THE ARTIST SITE IS TO PUT
THE TO READY TO GO IN PERFECT
CONDITION WE DON'T NEED TO SPEND
ALL THIS MONEY I'M LOOKING AT
ANOTHER STOP POSITION Q. WE HAVE
LINE ONE FORTY THREE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS TRACY
PROUT I'M A RESIDENT OF YOUR
BILL IN THAT IN THE PROXIMITY OF
THE JET PLAN CANYON I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE
THE TRAFFIC IS APPALLING IN THIS
AREA THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE
LINED ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS DR RICHARD
STARLET PRIMARY FORTY SEVEN YEAR
RESIDENT OF IRVINE I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE
UNLESS IT IS AMENDED BY THE
ORDER SORRY- THE ORDINANCE NEXT
WE ONLINE ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS MIDDLE
KINGDOM ON A LONG TIME RESIDENT
OF WOMAN. AND I STRONGLY IT.
FIFTY NINE FIVE. THANK YOU WE
HAVE LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO I HAD. HI MY NAME
IS MARK CINEMATIC I AM MURDERED
RESIDENT OF FEEL ABOUT INDIA HE
JUST CLOSED TO THROUGH EIGHT
HIRAM GIPSON GUIDANCE FOR
SENATORS AND REPRESENTATIVES
RESIDENTS HERE I SPOKE TO
HUNDREDS OF LAST MAJOR READY TO
HEAR THE THING OF MYSELF
STRONGER OPPOSED HAVING CEMETERY
HERE THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF HOMES
TO HAVE DIRECT VIEWS OF
INSURRECTION MCCARTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS WE HAVE LINED.
ONE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WITHOUT THE MY NAME
BECAUSE THEY PRINTER CALCULATOR
. I AM IN FRONT THE COURT OF AB
FIFTEEN THREE REPRESENTING AT
OUR MY FAMILY IS YOUR BILL AND
NEXT TO THE FIGHT AT WELL STRONG
. THANK YOU THANK WE HAVE LINE
ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE AHEAD. MY
NAME'S MICHELLE JOHNSON ALONG
URBAN RESIDENT VERY CHOI EIGHTY
FIVE I SUPPORTERS IF YOU CAN BUT
I SUPPOSE THE DISH PROVISIONS OF
SB THREE THEREFORE OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
NEXT WE HAVE LAND ONE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS JEFF
GRANT EASTER BELINDA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE FIFTY NINETY FIVE
DUE TO BAD TRAFFIC CONDITIONS
OUT HERE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TAX WE HAVE LAND ONE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TO PUT THEM AND I AM YOUR
POLITICAL. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
. THE IF YOU WANT. FIVE MILLION
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST DOUBLE CHECK IT
ONE MORE TIME AND EVEN ON THE
PHONES WITH OPPOSITION. ANYONE
IN THE CHAMBERS IN OPPOSITION.
MOVING TO THE COMMITTEE HAS ANY-
MEMBERS WISH TO COMMENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS. THANK YOU
AT MISTER CHAIR AND BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE MISTER BEAR
DINO I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
WORKING ALONG SIDE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA AND ALONGSIDE
MANY OF THE VETERANS I CALLED IN
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
NINETY FIVE AS HAS BEEN SAID ON
FOR TEN YEARS FOR TEN YEARS TO
BRING A VETERANS CEMETERY.
ORANGE COUNTY I'M AND I DO JUST
WANT TO. READ AND THEN CONFER
ASK A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR TO
CONFIRM SAID THERE'S A COUPLE OF
CLARIFYING POINTS IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT ARE VERY
RELEVANT. TO ADD SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE SO.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS STATES
THIS BILL DOES NOT PRIVILEGE THE
GYPSUM CANYON LOCATION BUT WOULD
MAKE IT ELIGIBLE ALONG WITH ANY
OTHER LOCATION IN ORANGE COUNTY
INCLUDING THE PREVIOUSLY
IDENTIFIED. EL TORO SITES.
ANNOUNCES GOES ON TO SAY THIS
BILL WOULD NOT RULE OUT
CONSTRUCTION OF A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS CEMETERY AT
EITHER OF THE PROPOSED SITES ON
THE FORMER MCAS EL TORO. FIVE
AND SO POINT ONE AND POINT TO
THAT IS MADE IN THE COMPANY
ANALYSIS. GOES ON TO SAY IT IS
ALSO NOT NECESSARY TO SPENT. A
PART IN STATUTE THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS CEMETERY WAS
BUILT NEAR READY WITH STATUTE
REQUIRING THAT IT BE FELT IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. I'M TAKE
RODNEY COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. IT
MEMBER CREW. THAT THAT IS IN
FACT IN ACCURATE SUMMARY OF
OTHERS TWO PROVISIONS CRACKED.
YES AND WE DELIBERATELY DID NOT
ADD GYPSUM CANYON IN THIS WE
WANTED TO KEEP IT OPEN TO ORANGE
COUNTY AS- YOU ALL KNOW THAT
THERE HAS BEEN- THE FIRST
ATTEMPT ARDA. THE SECOND ATTEMPT
THE STRAWBERRY FIELDS THE THIRD
ATTEMPT- THE GULF SITE AND NOW
THIS- PHILLY FOURTH ATTEMPT. NOW
WE CERTAINLY DID NOT EVER INTEND
TO HAVE FOUR POTENTIAL SITES.
AND WE TO MY FRIENDS HERE- WE
WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE THE
ARTIST SITE AS THE ORIGINAL SITE
AS THAT WAS THE FIRST SITE THAT
WAS PROPOSED. BUT FOR SOME OF
YOU WHO HAVE NOT- GONE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS WITH US THERE WERE
BALLOT MEASURES THERE WERE.
PEOPLE CALL TO SUPPORT- NINE
ORIGINAL SITE THERE WERE JUST AS
MANY WHO HAD CONCERNS WITH
TRAFFIC WITH FUNCTION WAY WITH A
SCHOOL SITE WITH HOMEOWNERS SO
ALL OF THE SITES DO- IN ESSENCE
BRING UP SOME OF THE SAME
COMMENTS SO WHETHER IT'S CHIPS
AND OR ARDA- BUT- THE REAL- MOVE
AWAY FROM IRVINE CAME. FROM THE
COUNCIL THE CITY COUNCIL AS WAS
MENTIONED VOTING THAT DOWN
SEVERAL TIMES AND I KNOW WAS
MENTIONED IN OPPOSITION THAT
THERE COULD BE A NEW COUNCIL
COMING IN NOVEMBER AND THAT'S
ALWAYS THE POTENTIAL BUT OUR JOB
IS TO SECURE. AS QUICKLY AS- A
SPACE. AS YOU HEARD SOME OF THE
MEMBERS CALLING ON THE LINES FOR
EIGHTY EIGHT YEARS OLD EIGHT
FIVE YEAR OLD. AND THE VETERANS
WE KNOW BEFORE AND DURING THIS
TEN YEAR PERIOD ARE PASSING AWAY
AND THAT IS THE URGENCY HERE BUT
YES ART IT DOES NOT EXCLUDE. YOU
FOR I NOT AND I'M LIKE IT'S JUST
OF THE LAST THING I WILL SAY IS
YOU KNOW- BERTINO AND YOUR
OPENING. I DESCRIBED IS A HARD
THING THAT YOU HAVE HAD. EVER
GRAPPLED WITH YOUR EXPERIENCE IN
THIS CAPITAL AND I THINK THAT
AND THE WAY IN WHICH WE HAVE
SEEN THIS TURNED INTO A
POLITICAL HOT POTATO. OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS HAS BEEN REALLY
SHAMEFUL AND I KNOW INCREDIBLY
HURTFUL TO SO MANY OF OUR LOCAL
VETERANS WHO SERVED OUR NATION
SO SELFLESSLY AND- I DO HOPE AND
I DO GENUINELY BELIEVE THAT. THE
ONE SAYING THAT SUPPORTERS AND
OPPOSITION CAN AGREE ON ABOUT
THIS IS THAT ORANGE COUNTY'S
VETERANS DESERVE A DEDICATED AND
DIGNIFIED RESTING PLACE- THAT
BEST FITS THEIR SERVICE TO OUR
COUNTRY. AND DIVE EIGHT YOU KNOW
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT- TO
HONORING OUR VETERANS AS WELL
AND- I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THANK YOU SO MUCH- FOR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUT OUT TAKE
THIS TIME TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
. RAMOS HI HERE THAT THE-
BOERNER HORVATH DALY HERE MATHIS
MURATSUCHI PETRIE-NORRIS HERE
SALAS SMITH. CORMS ESTABLISHED
THANK YOU WE HAVE- COMMENTS FROM
SENATOR MATHIS THEN WE'LL GO TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND IN THANK YOU
TO- OUR COLLEAGUE. MISS PETER
NORRIS THANK- THE POINTS ON THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS OR- VERY SPOT
ON. THIS HAS BEEN AN ONGOING
DECADES PLUS LONG CONVERSATION
AND- THE- YOU KNOW AND WE WE'VE
SEEN BACK AND FORTH EVEN BETWEEN
THE AUTHORS ON THIS LEGISLATION
BETWEEN MISS QUIRK-SILVA AND
MISTER CHOI AND TO SEE THEM COME
TOGETHER ON THIS TO SEE. YOU
KNOW NOT EVERYBODY'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE HAPPY. WHEN IT COMES
TO THESE THINGS AND
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN GOVERNMENT HAS TO AT THE
STATE LEVEL STEP UP AND PLAY THE
PART OF BIG BROTHER. AND SAY
OKAY WE'RE WE'RE DONE HERE WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD WE NEED TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN AND IN THIS
CASE WE NEED TO HONOR OUR
VETERANS. AND GET THIS DONE. AND
I WANT TO THANK DR CHOI AND. I'M
TRYING TO THINK AND I'M LIKE
SHARON- I DON'T THINK THE
AUTHORS. BECAUSE THIS ISN'T EASY
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE STILL
THIS TERM WHILE BACK ON THERE
STILL IS A DEBATE BACK HOME AND
IT'S NOT EASY TO SAY HEY WE'RE
GOING TO PUT A VETERANS CEMETERY
AND MIDDLE OF A LARGE URBAN AREA
. SO THANK YOU BOTH FOR THE
WORK. AND BUT GO AHEAD AND
MOTION TO MOVE THISBILL FOR NOW
WE OF COURSE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THAT SO THEY WERE DALY.
THANK YOU- AND I DO INTEND TO
SUPPORT THE BILL I THINK IT'S-
IT'S WELL THOUGHT OUT- SO I
SUPPORT MY COLLEAGUES. SHARON
QUIRK-SILVA THAT IS HER NAME-
SUPPORT THIS BILL- AND I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION TO SUPPORT THE
BILL JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS TO
GET A FEW DETAILS ON THE TABLE.
A MY UNDERSTANDING IS THERE. TO
PREVIOUS STUDIES. OF CEMETERY
SITES OF SITES FOR THIS CEMETERY
AND I WERE WONDERING I DID NOT
SEEN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND
I SHOULD HAVE TALKED TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF BEFORE THIS
HEARING HOW MUCH MONEY THE STATE
HAS SPENT ON THOSE TWO STUDIES.
AND I'M RECALLING EACH WAS
APPROXIMATELY 400-100-0500
THOUSAND. BALLPARK TO HAVE
HAPPEN TO KNOW THAT. OKAY THANK
YOU YOU'RE GONNA LOOK IT UP. BUT
LET'S JUST THOSE ARE BALLPARK
NUMBERS THAT THE STATE HAS
ALREADY SPENT ON STUDIES. AND
I'M ALSO WONDERING IS. I KNOW
THIS BILL PROPOSES TO STUDY.
LIKELY THE GYPSUM CANYON SIDE
ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT DESIGNATED BUT
DO WE HAVE A BALLPARK ESTIMATE
OF HOW MUCH THAT A CEMETERY AT
THAT SITE WILL COST. HENCE THE
NEED FOR A STUDY BUT THERE'S NO
BALLPARK ESTIMATE THERE'S NO
OKAY. I KNOW THE COUNTY HAS
COMMITTED FUNDING. FOR THE
POTENTIAL CEMETERY AT THAT SITE
SO I JUST WANT TO FLEISCH THOSE
POINTS OUT. AND- IF WE CAN'T
OBTAIN UNANSWERED TODAY MAYBE
YOU COULD COMMUNICATE TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF. MISTER
CHAIR IF THAT'S ACCEPTABLE TO
YOU- THE CHAIR WILL GET THE
INFORMATION QUÉ YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CHAIR RAMOS AND- I
INTEND TO SUPPORT THIS BILL SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
VICE CHAIR VOEPEL. YES AS A
VETERAN- I'M LOOKING AT THE
VALLEY HERE. INTER'S QUITE A
FEW- INDIVIDUAL HOUSES. AND THE
POSE VETERANS CEMETERY WOULD BE
MORE UP THE HILLSIDE. WITH A
LINE OF SIGHT NOW THERE IS A
BIAS AGAINST CEMETERIES IN
GENERAL PEOPLE ARE KIND OF
AFRAID OF THEM- I GREW UP.
NEAREST CEMETERY AND MY FATHER
ALWAYS TOLD ME THE SAFEST PLACE
ON THE PLANET IS IN A CEMETERY
NO ONE'S GOING TO MESS WITH YOU
- SO. I AM CONCERNED IT MAY BE A
LITTLE BIT OF PUSH BACK HERE IS
JUST SIMPLY. HAVING A CEMETERY
IN THE SIGHTLINE ON DO
TOMBSTONES SO IT COULD BE AS
SIMPLE AS THAT THE OTHER THING
IS TRAFFIC. IN MY EXPERIENCE
WITH VETERANS CEMETERIES THE
MAIN TRAFFIC WOULD BE ON
MEMORIAL DAY. AND WHAT'S
INTERESTING IS EVERYBODY'S OFF
ON MEMORIAL DAY SO YOU DON'T
HAVE BIG TRAFFIC ISSUES BECAUSE
IT'S A HOLIDAY. IN MAINLY THE
PEOPLE THAT GO TO A VETERANS
CEMETERY ON MEMORIAL DAY OR
VETERANS FAMILIES. SO THE
TRAFFIC ISSUE IS REALLY A NON
STARTER ARE YOU ALSO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE TRAFFIC AT
CHRISTMAS. BECAUSE A LOT OF
VETERANS FAMILIES WILL PUT A
CHRISTMAS TREE ON A GRAVE. OR
REEF AND ENFORCE JULY OF COURSE.
SO I AM NOT CONVINCED AT ALL
THAT THERE'S A TRAFFIC PROBLEM.
IT WITHOUT GETTING TOO LONG
WINDED I ALWAYS REMIND PEOPLE.
ABOUT VETERANS WE CELEBRATE
THREE HOLIDAYS EVERY YEAR. THE
FIRST IS ARMED FORCES DAY AS FOR
EVERYONE WEARING A UNIFORM. WE
HAVE VETERANS DAY FOR EVERYONE
WORE THE UNIFORM WE HAVE
MEMORIAL DAY FOR ALL THOSE THAT
NEVER MADE IT OUT OF UNIFORM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
ANY OTHER- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WISHING TO COMMENT. HEARING
NONE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES THANK YOU I DID WANT
TO ADDRESS A FEW OF THE
QUESTIONS ON THE STUDIES AND YES
THAT HAS BEEN- A LITTLE TRICKY
AT- THERE WERE. THREE SITES
PROPOSED IN IRVINE ONE WAS NOT
STUDIED THE STRAWBERRY SITE BUT
THE GULF SITE AND ARDA- I
BELIEVE EACH OF THEM WERE. ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND SO TO A
MILLION AND FOR BOTH OF THOSE
THIS NEXT ONE- GIPSON CANYON. WE
HAVE PUT UP TO SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN THERE- I HAVE HEARD
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WHAT IS
THE COUNTIES- INVESTMENT IN THIS
AS FAR AS PUTTING UP MONEY AND
NATIONALLY FOR THAT VERSUS CAL
THAT. ONE OF THE REASONS- THAT
WE WERE WORKING WITH CALVET TO
DO THIS STUDY IS THE URGENCY
PART OF IT OTHERWISE WE'D HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
START OVER ON SOME OF THIS. BUT
THE CAMERA COUNTY IS PUTTING IN
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITION TO THE TWENTY THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION THAT NOT ONLY
MYSELF BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
AND SENATOR TOM- BURKE- HAVE
WERE ABLE TO SECURE WHICH ADDS.
IS THAT TWENTY THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION SO AND ASK TO HAVE THE
TWENTY MILLION ACCOUNT PLUS THE
ADDITIONAL. MONEY THAT IS THERE-
THAT DOES NOT MEAN WE WANT TO
JUST A ROAD MONEY JUST TO STUDY
ANY SITE BUT THIS IS A TWO
HUNDRED ACRE SITE- THEY'RE
HAVING QUESTIONS WOULD- THIS
VETERANS CEMETERY BE COMBINED
WITH THE PUBLIC CEMETERY. THEY
WILL NOT BE COMBINED THERE WILL
BE A SUB PUBLIC CEMETERY- IN A
DIFFERENT PART OF THIS- PARCEL
OF LAND WITH ITS OWN OPERATING
NOT FROM CAL THAT FROM THE WATCH
COUNTY CEMETERY DISTRICT. THE
ORANGE COUNTY CEMETERY DISTRICT
WILL BE PUTTING IN QUITE A BIT
OF INFRASTRUCTURE AS FOR AS A
ROADS AND OTHER- INVESTMENTS TO
GET THIS PROPERTY. YEAH I WOULD
SAY AS FAR AS SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION- THIS PARCEL SITS
KIND OF ON A HILLSIDE IN ANAHEIM
HILLS AND THERE IS A FREE WAY
THAT. DOESN'T GO THROUGH THE
PROPERTY BUT THAT RUNS- OUR
PARALLEL TO THIS PROPERTY SO
THERE ARE NO HOMES DIRECTLY IN
THE VICINITY THERE ACTUALLY
ACROSS. THE FREEWAY WHICH IS
SEVERAL LANES QUITE A BIT
DISTANCE AWAY AND THEN LASTLY
SOME MYTHS ABOUT THAT THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY BE- HAVING A CREMATORY
THERETHAT IS ABSOLUTELY FALSE
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD NEVER BE
ON SITE SO I JUST WANT. TO THE
PEOPLE KNOW THAT THIS IS A
THOUGHTFUL PROPOSAL- AND URGE
ANY OF YOU TO GO OUT TO THIS
CHIPS INSIDE I MYSELF PERSONALLY
WAS A LITTLE HESITANT AFTER
THREE SITES AND IRVINE AND IT
REALLY WAS GOING OUT ON THAT IF
YOU WANT TO SAY SITE TRIP. THAT
DEFINITELY HAD ME CHANGE MY VIEW
AND LOOK AT THE POSSIBILITY AND
I THINK THAT IT WOULD BE A VERY
BEAUTIFUL REST. FOR OUR THAT SH.
THAT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THIS BILL ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
TO SECOND THE MOTION BEFORE US
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. RAMOS I REMOVED I VOEPEL
VOEPEL I BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I DAILY DAILY
AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE MURATSUCHI
. PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
SALAS SMITH SMITH I SALAS SALAS
I. AND- COOL IF THERE EIGHT ZERO
BILLS OUT TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE MOTION
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR SECOND
. SECOND SECOND SECOND THIRD
CAN'T ORGANIZER FOR THE MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS RAMOS HI
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL VOEPEL AYE
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I DAILY DAILY AYE MATHIS. MATHIS
I AM MURATSUCHI. ADRIN NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS I SALAS SALAS
ICEMAN. THANK YOU THANK YOU A
SERVER DAY SMETANA CONCERN
CALENDAR THE THOUGHT CONSENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIDE HI IT'S
EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL WE WILL KEEP THE OVERALL
OPEN. BROTHER MEMBERS ARE ACTION
. OKAY.
S.
YOU. NUMBER I AM SENDING YOU A.
THANKS FOR.
HE'S ON HIS WAY.
THANK OKAY FIVE MINUTES TO GO
BEFORE FOUR. FOUR FOUR. FOUR
DOLLARS. THE FOLLOWING. HOW IT
YOUR BILL YEAH- ARE THEY- THE
FINAL RESPONSIBLENESS. AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI HI AND ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
AYE THE NINE ZERO THANK YOU.